we had a staff christmas party which was
weird we did it over zoom i don't want
to say anything bad about gary but uh
like everyone goes hey howard's here
give a speech and i wasn't really
planning on saying anything because it's
weird but i'm like you know hey i just
want to tell you how grateful i am to
everybody and you know for the job
they're doing it and i look on my screen
and you know of course the one person
it's focused on is gary and he's stuff
in his mouth the whole time i'm giving
this speech like
he's eating his meal i was just like
gary's like chomping away on like why is
he doing that like
because on zoom it's like you know
you've got a close-up of somebody
yeah
i know the idea
is to like everyone's to get a meal and
bring their meal to their butt but you
know what if it was me and i was gary i
would eat my meal before and not eat in
front of everybody but but
so this is the internal dialogue going
in my head i'm like am i his
entertainment or something
gary why didn't you eat before a party
it was bad timing on the delivery that's
all i could say yeah because you know
what it is
i'm being serious now no [ __ ] with
zoom
the person who pops up on your screen
especially when you're on your phone is
the person who's talking
gary was eating so loud with his teeth
that's why he's watching
that's not true because it's true i was
mute i muted it when i know you were
right because every time you went
i'm telling you you popped up on my
screen why did you pop up over let's say
chris wilding or robin or anybody else
again i apologize all right no again i'm
not trying to single you out well what
are you trying to do i'm just trying to
say why do you eat exactly what you're
trying to do oh why don't why are you
eating on zoom like why would you do
that you know people goof on you i
thought we i thought we were all
supposed to have our dinner there i'm
missing turkey of course we are but who
doesn't no one except you you're sitting
there stuffing himself what were you
eating by the way i think it was chicken
parm
yeah chicken parm which by the way is a
messy food i i know chicken parm is like
you're going to get that
chewing
oh he was
each bite was like 25 chews
i won't find you i'm talking
no no i actually thought that afterwards
even mary said are we supposed to be
eating i was like that's what they said
to do and she was like
and like so i get it i
lesson learned point taker don't listen
to everybody
i saw those chickens going into that
mouth i was like they
it was like that walk to death row and
he's staring at me like like it's a tv
show he's watching that's just and i'm
saying that as a friend i'm not trying
to will not happen again i i agree all
right okay all right
you